my guest tonight of course won an Emmy
Award for his portrayal of Jack
McFarland on the hit series Will and
Grace he's got a new movie out he wrote
and he stars in it it's called lazy
susan it's available on video on demand
April 3rd and this is a good time to be
watching video on demand please welcome
our really good friend mr. Sean Hayes
Sean thanks for being here thank you do
I hold for the applause like are you
gonna put the applause in there will be
no applause oh so we just go right into
it yeah you know the way normally
there'd be some applause for you sure
now there's just nothing I'm kind of
used to it I know people like you and I
are similar in that we both the times
that you and I have gotten together and
like had dinner we're both doing bits
the whole time you know people like us
who have to be quarantined yeah I'm
performing for like pillows yeah I feel
like I've trained my mind and body to be
quarantined my whole life oh really yeah
so it's finally paying off so you're
saying you were socially distant saying
since when what my whole well you know
this virus has caused us to be socially
distant I'm actually waiting for the
virus that causes us to be emotionally
distant I think I caught it a long time
ago
you got that around like nine years old
you think mm-hmm I was like that and he
just gave it to me have you guys been
fate going on you know whatever
facetiming yeah well you know who knew
what zoom was until this started right
did you see that video that went viral
about no pun intended that this woman
was on like a meeting a zoom meeting
with all of her co-workers and she took
the day but I've heard about it tell me
I was like you know there's like 50
windows open and she literally just
takes her laptop and walks all the way
to the bathroom
pulls her pants down and goes to the
bathroom
and first of all there's so many things
to break that let's break that down one
bringing a laptop into the bathroom at
any point your life yeah yeah
why are you doing it during an office
meeting
Bird Lake and then and then it's really
asked up that her that somebody recorded
it and then posted it oh my god yeah
yeah there's so many things wrong with
it the Tiger King makes more sense than
this no I was the way everyone's
enjoying Tiger King right now how could
you not did you watch the whole thing I
haven't watched the whole thing yet I'm
but halfway through I love it is
astonishing it's it's still not as good
as someone taking their laptop into the
door there's a rumor going around the
business the show business that you
facetimed with Oprah and Maria Shriver
is that true yeah
Maria Shriver started this fun thing
where she just calls people like around
six o'clock friends and she's like let's
let's do FaceTime and I'll bring him fun
guests surprise fun guest I'm like great
comedy and so it was just me Scottie and
Maria no prod we just had a really good
time and then did I lose you yeah none
and then well we chatted about the
current events and it was fun I mean but
well mate Oprah joins you okay joint
that's insane that's that's not
something that most people can relate to
well well
me and you were talking right now why
would Noah and I be talking or over and
you you're right butor I'm saying for a
second I forgot my cell Conan Oh Sean I
had no idea it was you I took mine off
for clarity and you put yours on yeah I
yeah I'm gonna pretend that that would
be no big deal for me to talk to Oprah
well of course you're like oh my gosh
Maria
tell me was Oprah and then and and but
then you talk to Oprah for five minutes
you realize Oprah's Oprah because she's
completely of the earth yeah like she's
grounded and regular and fun and
easygoing and smart and all this things
that she emits there's a push in the
news that she's quarantined Stedman is
that right has Stedman in quarantine I
think the story is that she quarantined
Stedman but starting six years ago
that's what I heard this story is that
Stedman was traveling I think and you
know Oprah had just gotten over from
being sick and so she was very scared so
yeah okay don't worry none of that's
going in okay you're home all day yeah
with and you we're in a similar
situation which is I'm home with Liza
you're home with Scottie and I'm gonna
be honest I'll speak first we're doing
pretty well we're doing pretty well
being together but there are moments
where I can tell I'm driving her crazy
are you getting along oh I'm for sure
driving you crazy yeah no I yeah I mean
you know we turned one of our bedrooms
into a gym so we could you know work out
we didn't have a gym here and and it's
above us right now but you can't hear it
and so right now he's actually working
out and it's um it drives me bananas
right he jumped up and running around
and so it feels like an earthquake and
the whole thing's gonna fall them and
it's for like a really long time well
why is he running around I I mean you've
got the weights and the yoga ball that's
all well you need tell Scottie to stop
running around it sounds like he's
there's a fire or something you're like
old people in New York now but I've met
Scotty
I know Scotty he seems like it could be
very easy to get along with and then
he'd be sort of I mean he's a guy that
what he'd probably just be happy
watching a movie right let me tell you
something let me tell you something
right now
you're right Scotty is the easiest going
guy everybody loves him I would say when
the time comes hopefully not for many
many many years when he ends up in a
nursing home he's gonna the easiest
person to take care of because he loves
what movies he just could watch movies
all day long
you just walk into the nursing room you
put on Star Wars and I leave and that's
all it's gonna take
I wish I was kidding
like literally watch this Scotty it's
the force awakens and then you're good
for like three hours right and then you
go off you go to in-and-out burger and
you have a good time well I live my life
you live my life when my time comes and
I'm elderly my family knows to put on my
shows beginning in 1993 and just let
them roll and I'll sit there and I'll
say I don't know how he did it
uh-huh and when do they start that soon
very soon okay that's what we're about
about we're about three months away from
that
I don't know if you want this out there
but that's kind of when I was at your
house we did this is really
uncomfortable you've revealed something
a little uncomfortable for me but I
might as well we're all being honest now
during this time of national crisis so
yes what sean has just revealed is that
when guests come to my home you're given
a drink you're escorted into a large
room where my show since 1993 are
running are already running right it's
already start let me ask you about lazy
susan because i love this this is you
playing a woman yeah so I hmm
when I was 21 years old I was living in
Chicago I grew up in Chicago and I got a
call from my agent saying um you have an
audition tomorrow to replace the white
guy on in living color
and I was like wait Jim Carrey is
leaving the show and she said yeah and
so I went with my
like wigs and accents and characters and
all these things that I've worked on and
and one of the characters was this this
this girl this woman Susan and and I'm
still waiting to hear if I got part but
then we cut to like decades later a
friend of mine was like you know what
you should do something with that
character was so funny and you should
call it lazy susan and I was like gosh I
love that title and I'm like a light
bulb went off and I thought what a
wonderful kind of built in somatic
reason to talk you know to portray a
person who's spinning out of control
like a lazy susan who can't figure out
their life and so and then I'm top of it
I was like I've never seen I thought it
might be out there but I've never seen a
film where a man plays a woman without
any like other kind of underlying
pretext you know to do the thing where
the comedy comes from the character not
the fact that a man is playing a woman
we have a still but you are you are
quite convincing do you like yourself as
Susan do you like yourself as as a woman
I like
I personally for me I do not enjoy
dressing up as a woman not to judge
those who do things are really rough
over there with you and Liza oh they're
actually better than ever I'm I'm
getting to be their real me at long last
we have a clip here from lazy susan i
don't even know if you know about about
this clip you may know i think i may are
we am i gonna watch it or you play put
it in after we don't we put it in
afterwards
yeah in fact we're gonna replace you
with another actor you're gonna be
played by richard kind okay again yeah
again i'm closing don't get me a present
oh yes me i got you
here's some headbands awesome
that's some crazy glue oh yeah I go
crazy
meatloaf gets ate up are you going to
the hospital again for meal of day what
[Music]
maybe you didn't feel good me to say
there is no fill people don't call me
people I told you I hate that at the
word out lazy susans gonna be available
on video and demand everywhere April 3rd
there is no better time right now than
for good streaming content I mean this
is actually you know it's I'm watching a
ton of great stuff just because that's
what you do now we are yeah we are all
home and so I'm grateful to people like
you that have made good news stuff that
I can watch well thank you my dear yeah
I'm really excited about it really proud
about it and and I'll be watching all
your movies okay that's Bob there look I
never tried I tried for a while to make
it in film but it just didn't pop for me
that's all well I'm sorry I didn't
succeed incredibly at doing I've never
been in a movie and I've always thought
I would look horrible on a movie screen
well I got a little I've aim that would
be 60 feet tall little squirrely thin
lips well you got you well the good news
is nobody goes to the theater anymore so
I had to wait for movies to die but I
could drive into so your 60-foot vein is
now 30 feet this is the right medium for
me it's taken me 30 years but I finally
figured it out
Thank You Shawn thank you so much please
give my best to Scotty tell him to stop
jumping up and down on top of you and
really thank you so much for being here
everyone check out lazy susan and i will
see you soon in better times okay man
thank you
you thank you bye